a night game with Memphis inside 20  brought by kuzmic got it back big fella  turns in a crowd continues to fight  blocked again the blonde is on the court  with no shoes my job what is going on  here that's some disrespect right there  please and then look at LeBron on to the  court no shoes on yeah he'd given his  shoes away to a fan behind the Laker  bench  LeBron signing shoes  two pairs going up with a couple of  young fans and I mean what a moment  one ball that's to one pier a 1k good  other maybe he had two pairs going up  now  what does Shoei one shooting about that  site that's about the fourth time I've  seen LeBron do that on the road this  year  [Applause]  [Music]